subject for today
[Music]
yeah i do love this cigar hold on a
second someone else start talking
because i realized
good morning mug club is on here
wednesday and i don't want people to
know my favorite cigar because there's a
shortage oh my gosh yeah
so uh hello ash wentz it's
too late it was on camera michael noel
already taken you can't see that don't
know another about this uh welcome to
ash wednesday i'm not gonna give my
favorite cigar because
it's all for me uh half asian lawyer
bill richmond is here
reg is here in studio thank you audio
weight quarter black garrett
this is where you can send your request
to us at uh littlecode.com
requests you can send in tweets uh less
political just uh you know
we shoot the bull but never shoot no
dear do you guys remember that the old
dear hunting song in wisconsin
it's niche somebody loved that reference
yeah
of course someone up there on the duck
blind i don't know
thank god for spotify podcasts that
rogan showed him who's boss
that was my shitty duck call and now
they're mad i can't do it
well it's great for our topic today
because i know our first question is
everyone's favorite impression of duck
calls
and that's just where mine is where i do
my impression of duck dynasty and i
condemn the homosexuals
oh
of course many people have forgotten
officer david dorne who was uh killed
serving his community
in the riots we didn't so you can buy
this shirt at loudwshop.com and every
nickel every dime every loony every
toonie every peso
will go uh to the family of uh david
dorn to hopefully help support him
uh because a lot of these people you
know they're forgotten this is one thing
the left does really well they
they remember a lot of people often
false heroes whether it's people like
mike brown or you know a lot of these
people in the black lives matter
movement and then we sort of find out
what actually happened and they just
sort of deify the person regardless of
actions
this was a good man this was a man who
served his community this was a man who
uh there was no reason for him to die
and uh i think uh from what we know
pretty good role model uh
also i hit the notification bell because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
and you can subscribe on the itunes is
that it some kind of thing
some kind of the apple podcast some kind
of musical singing robot
yes i don't know but when you hit
subscribe it'll sing it to you elon musk
hits a blunt
so whoa i don't know what's the pairing
of the week preparing of the week
is lfd anniversio and makers
46 anniversario i'm not horrible
you're a horrible mexican
he's not very good at it what was that i
don't know what were you doing you were
doing the skipper from uh
pairing his espresso with jameson so it
is early that sounds absolutely terrible
um well thank you for your praying
that's the floor dominicana
i know that rush limbaugh and dennis
prager both really like the florida
minicon
it's not really my speed i don't tend to
like dominican tobacco a whole bunch
my speed speed speed yeah sometimes like
a speed ball
which i'm bringing i'm dragging myself
into
deep waters because i don't know what a
speed ball is is it methamphetamine with
a drug is it coke with i think it's coke
and a heroin right
is it really no no no it's one of those
things you put into the dryer so you're
closing
dryer yeah yeah oh i thought that was a
shamwow
i use that very improperly i was so
distracted by the ambassador
that i was putting shamrows in the dryer
soaked up they're not dryer sheets
i should have known better shamwell uh
let's go to our first
question again a lot of clutter.com ask
uh send me your video questions and of
course we can see your tweets
this first question is what is your
favorite non-alcoholic drink
see i'm a better mexican what was i
i don't understand i like i like saying
it like i'm a bird
waiting to be fed by my mother
oh well that's getting photoshopped oh
boy you had to say it garrett
[Laughter]
the only reason i learned it was because
my friend was hispanic his child speaks
spanish and kept
demanding uh awa and he was he was
completely just neglected oh
yeah that sounds funny he was dehydrated
he was like
they're like like oh i don't know
anything like baby talk
[Laughter]
oh what you know what he's fine now a
little genius instead he got some toppo
um my favorite non-alcoholic drink
typically water i do like tobacco i do
like
uh chico's really good really good clear
um
and then as far as sodas some but part
of my routine in the morning is if i
when i have my black rifle coffee of
course uh blackrafflecoffee.com
crowder i love the black rifle coffee it
is what i drink every morning i'll often
have like one of those small seven ounce
coke zeros
okay yeah yeah yeah so and then here i
have a uh dr pepper 10. i don't i find
that diet sodas aren't really great
because then those ones are like peppers
diet soda though is it
the 10 is better it tastes like normal
dr pepper and then my favorite
like treat is i think i had some with
you that uh spreckers from wisconsin
going back to the wisconsin hunting
crowd sprecker's low calorie root beer
yeah
that was that was that was pretty tasty
that was going to be that's up on my
list now
yeah it is because it's not super rupee
doesn't need to be that sweet
it already has a bunch of herbs a lot of
earthy tones a lot of herbs in so i'm
going to ask this
i actually have a number of
non-alcoholic drinks that i like but
it's dependent on location
so for example i will never buy ginger
ale
or apple juice but if i'm staying at a
hotel and i go to breakfast in the
morning i always drink apple juice if
it's available
and when i'm on a plane i will always
drink ginger ale you drink ginger ale
yeah
ginger ale i usually actually get them
separate yeah and i will drink the
whiskey first then another oh i can
chase another
then i'll drink the ginger but for some
reason i don't know and i know a lot of
people who do ginger ale on the plane
only
i don't know about the apple juice thing
i'm probably weird but i don't know if
it like contextually
i don't know he's reverting to a state
of childhood reverting
sweet hurting apple juice
you know what's funny um ginger ale and
bourbon that's the most like i've never
really been
hungover um i don't but i don't really
drink to get drunk but once i did
accidentally have way too much to drink
it was the mitt romney barack obama
debates i was in grand rapids michigan i
had the worst sore throat
i had a friend who made me like a hot
toddy and then he said
like that's a lot of work right now and
i'm exhausted he said well you know try
some bourbon and ginger ale so i got a
big bottle of evan williams i was
watching those debates
and i had no idea as to uh size i'm a
beer guy yeah
so i was putting like a pint glass and i
was like a tulip pint glass i was
putting
probably about six ounces of evidence
and then ginger really
like four or five and i just i had a
really bad headache
um you know i uh i at that point i
wasn't very clear-headed the next
morning i felt fine
but i have never had evan williams since
wow that's good
never going back it'll get you bourbon
and ginger ale is a nice combination but
it'll trick you yeah
jamieson and ginger yeah is it really
nice yeah so what are your favorite
non-alcoholic drinks
real quick i'm like bill whenever i go
to a hotel
and i see cranberry juice i just get so
excited
it's delicious your urinary tract thanks
you yeah yeah no but i
i i guess i'm the 30 year old boomer the
meme because i love the white monster
energy drinks
i actually do find that if i don't have
coffee that's what i go for
or the old the old school white rock
star i know most people don't like that
but that's usually what i go for
yeah so my favorite is the white monster
it's
i don't know something about that flavor
sometimes i even wish that they made
like a caffeine free version
because i want to like drink it right
before i go to sleep yeah you want to
have one of those you know what's pretty
good though
neuro drinks neural bliss right those
are good yeah the blue one is the neural
bliss once i don't know what it does
it's supposed to be relaxing i know
there's nothing in there really bad for
you it's just like c9 and vitamin d
yeah but it is pretty tasty later in the
day it's kind of similar to the white
monster yeah so yeah yeah well you guys
pass me over those aren't
yeah these are pretty good yeah they're
actually they're not bad and they have
the energy one too the neurosonic those
are good
then there was wasn't there any minor
orgasms i don't i'm not familiar with
that i have no idea
maybe that was a different story you
what are your favorite
what are your favorite
yeah you float to the surface and if you
don't it's fizzy you know
it's nice yeah if you do it right you
can do the dr pepper dolphin birth oh
where are the dolphins well it's you
know they're supposed to do it in the
ocean so at that point the dr pepper's
quite diluted
oh no yeah with salt water
[Laughter]
i'm gonna try and drink it end up like
ron paul at debate number four
we're now joe biden uh what's your
favorite theory audio aid
i really i really like a good sparkling
water i'll drink a gatorade after work
usually
but yeah most of the time it's just what
color what color yeah i got yellow
gatorade the lemon lime
okay okay it's like i think it hurts
that's the original right
it's the best one that's pine salt
that's basically pine salt
whoa pine salt it's lemon lime yeah i
like that lime i do like the red one
though
fruit punch red one number three i don't
like the fruit punch it's way too sweet
uh here i'm really lighting this cigar
do you hate anyone you remember all
sport
that was shaq because there was like
there was gatorade then power raid and
there was like an
arms race for crappy hydra did anyone
out there remember all sports shaquille
o'neal was
all sport it was physical i feel like
this is something that
you know you as a foreigner had no no no
all sport wasn't a
shaquille o'neal i mean i don't think
shaquille o'neal was only selling to
canada
i got confused because i was drinking a
whole thing of icy hot
so i guess i got my shakeology how did
it feel that i felt like i was blending
up
john's and putting it in or a general
insurance which one is he in now
all right you've had your fun
[Laughter]
oh no all sport i don't remember all
sport no not at all okay
maybe someone out there remember maybe
it was a canadian thing i have no idea
uh we were also talking about this a
play-doh for kids
yeah that is not fair when you have
play-doh that looks like a strawberry
it smells like a strawberry but then if
the kid eats it he's going to shorten
his lifespan by 18 years
i didn't know that you know i don't know
why they do i mean i'm just saying
you're not supposed to eat it i don't
know if it's toxic now they say
non-toxic but i remember that change
which
makes you which presumes it was toxic
beforehand
yeah why make something that looks and
smells delicious
but could kill you or it's just weirdly
are we talking about chapstick
maybe like making the uh making the
packing peanuts that come with your
packages
smell like uh like cheeseburgers
why would you eat those kyle because i'm
five
i don't know if anything it looks
delicious it smells like cherries
kyle is fine by the way audience yeah he
just needs some away
let's go to
a video question yeah okay hey crowder
and company this is garrett
i just wanted to ask you guys real quick
what do you think are the
most important aspects of lifestyle that
need to be compatible between two people
for a long-term relationship to be
successful
thank you for everything you guys do
hope you have a good one see you around
you're not gary he's getting yeah one of
the good ones what are you doing
i don't know which one to shoot um
too soon this is pretty i don't know
what are you talking about what are you
doing garrett's
shooting oh oh oh no foster
he's never too soon um
no that's just different if you aim an
ak-47 at a car i don't consider it
i don't consider it a surprise it's not
like
he was so quiet we never would have
expected this would you have expected it
after he aimed in ak-47 and well you
know okay
i mean now that you bring that up i do
appreciate though just on that point
like how pro-gun
people have to be to make that argument
right i'll be like no no he's totally
fine to
harriet and then point it and then oh
but uh ooh
yeah yeah but anti-gun safety that's
when you switch back to anderson cooper
right
yeah maybe that's just like all this
time we were advocating for responsible
gun ownership and second amendment
realized all we needed to do was aim it
at civilians with their finger on the
trigger and the left would have gotten
on board
loves it they would have been the next
charleston heston
um you know that's a good question uh
you know we talk about this quite a bit
in life advice
i think that you can make a lot of
aspects of a relationship work i don't
think that you need to find someone
where you have everything in common for
example sometimes you're like oh we need
the same
like the same movies like the same books
no you don't have to have the same
hobbies
it really does come down to sharing the
same fundamental values
i don't know how people out there james
carville does i
don't understand how you can make it
work if you're a conservative this
person is a liberal and i don't mean
that maybe they're moderate and not
necessarily interested in politics but
someone whose
fundamental worldview is diametrically
opposed to yours i don't know how you
raise children
i don't know how you have a relationship
i've never understood it
but if you have those values in line and
also
expectations and values as it relates to
the relationship itself and roles in the
relationship
if you agree on those almost everything
else can work
and some people think it's not romantic
because it's not this idea of
you know uh the one and love is a mini
splendid thing but
you know the truth is eventually you
choose somebody and
that passion wears off at some point and
you get it back you choose to continue
acting on that and so you both need to
be on the same page
when you enter into that relationship
it's the only way i've seen it work
what about friendships if that's maybe
that's what he was asking what long-term
friendships is it
as required did you say friendship i'm
pretty confident
but no that's that actually is i think
different did he say friendships no no
no he said long-term
role you want another friend named
garrett you want to be garrett and
gabriel hey gary
meet garrett garrett meet garrett he's
not mexican
that's the introduction for you now
thank you uh no for friendships
uh friendships i don't know no with guys
is different
you can have someone you disagree with
on a whole lot with guys politically and
still
then it comes down to more so values
like
loyalty um honesty you know not all of
my friends now the truth is now today in
2020 you don't really find that in a lot
of leftists
unfortunately you find it in classical
liberals who maybe support
higher taxes but people who believe in
shouting someone down with a boombox and
lighting their car on fire
not really someone i want with me in the
foxhole yeah yeah well
yeah people if you're headed toward
marriage if that's your goal
then um trust is going to be a big deal
if and and that is based on again an
underlying set of values because you're
going to be making decisions with this
other person and so being able to work
within the same framework you're not
going to be around that person every
time they're making the decision
my wife's at home with my kids right now
i'm not around her every single second
of the day
but i trust her with that and she can
trust me with a bunch of other stuff so
it's like
trust is going to be important and the
values that underlie that trusters
essentially yeah yeah and i'm not the
best person to ask this advice because i
started on second base
huge penis what were you about to say
there uh reg
oh no i was thinking back to the
friendships i think it makes it easy
sure yeah okay it gives me a third leg
up second base has
i can't remember but i think as far as
friendships go didn't see us lewis say
something like you know
friendships are born out of you know
looking at someone else and saying oh
you too you have this interest right and
so
i think especially for guys a shared
interest can you can build a friendship
on that
right without particularly anything else
in common i had
guys that i would you know do power
lifting competitions with we trained
together
we'd go to the meets i had a guy a close
friend who was a muslim so i'd be
sitting there reading my bible
sharing a hotel room with him and he'd
be like praying towards mecca and then
we get up the next day and max out and
squats bench and deadlifts did you ever
cancel out his prayers no no i didn't
um we were in different that's how it
works well i do that sometimes
we were in different weight classes but
no i think a shared interest
you can really bond over that in you
know politics religion other things
don't have to come into the mix
right marriage is obviously different
because if you try to do that you'll be
pulling
in two opposite directions and that's
where the sort of biblical analogy of
being yoked together with someone
you've gotta if you're yolked two
animals yoked together they've got to be
going the same way right that's a bit
that's the main thing especially
yeah you were trying to yeah you ever
tried a yolk yaks very strong animals
every day
but we can we can um you know if you
yoke yeah we're talking about by the way
i want to be really clear
equal opportunity for the yaks as far as
but not equal outcomes not all yaks
there's no equal outcome guaranteed for
yak so you yolk them equally as far as
opportunity go ahead
so i agree i think when it comes to the
relationships you often have to have
a similar goal and and you have to be
able to know that when that person is
making a decision
that you can generally understand like
i'm not saying like you're
speaking english right yeah oh yeah
communication yeah it's pretty freaking
key yeah you know
but but ultimately that that speaks to
the higher center like where are we
headed like where are we going to be in
five 10 20 years
what do we want our kids to be what kind
of relationships do we want to have all
of that means that you know you've got
to have
some level of kind of core compatibility
even if you have
you know you watch tv in different rooms
because you like different shows or one
of you likes to
you know shoot guns and the other one
likes to go play golf or like whatever
you know
which one are you in your relationship
likes to play golf uh me
so you like to shoot guns and play golf
yeah what's your wife doing
she's just hanging out she's very
understanding she's she's a very
tolerant person
patient um but i think with friendships
you're right
you know there's there's no question
like for example um you know i play in a
band and we have a variety of people on
all spectrums
we were recording a song actually a
couple weeks ago for a new album and we
had
the producer was a small business
conservative from new york he's like
i i have conservatism is in my blood
because of how i've seen
small businesses being treated under
certain policies in the state of new
york and how that's affected my family
and their in my grandparents and stuff
like that
and then we had another gentleman also
from new york uh an immigrant who lived
in brooklyn had a more
leftist type of view and over the course
of one of our breaks like we were
recording we took a break we're you know
having a drink eating some food
talked about politics for about 30
minutes and then wrapped it up and got
back done and yeah
you know it it doesn't have to be
because you're not always having to go
to the same place
do the same things trust them with your
kids or your finances or your
decisions a little bit different church
yeah yeah and i think with men in
particular we were talking about this
earlier how kind of
in the power lifting community there was
sort of a lot of common ground of
kinship with the combat sports community
whether it was jiu jitsu or even
collegiate wrestling
the reason for that is a i think it's
because it's an individual sport you
know
so much training comes down to a moment
where it's all on you there's a lot of
similarities between
strength sports and combat sports um
there's an intensity as well as kind of
you you go out there alone but you do
train with a team of people so yeah
forge in the fire and there is something
to be said
for men particularly while we're getting
off relationships going more into the
territory of friendships
of being in some kind of a fight some
kind of a battle together some kind of a
struggle does
definitely seem to forge a bond or uh
you see relationships fracture
because you know you can also i think
all of us at some point have had a
relationship where
okay it was tested and the person folded
and you realize you cannot trust that
person so even if you're not necessarily
if you don't share the same
political values or maybe political
policies
i would say because the difference
between for example a lot of muslims and
christians they're actually probably
very similarly aligned with a lot of
values outside of you know
like we believe that women can get in
the driver's seat in the volvo it's not
you know ain't going to mean all that
much to me um
but uh yeah if you share those values
and you do see some loyalty and some
trust and people
who will be there when you need them
that's what's most important in a male
relationship but yeah you can have
a common interest and everything kind of
revolves around that and sometimes
you'll have friendships where it really
just revolves around a common interest
and you don't talk about a whole
lot of other things whereas in a
relationship with a woman
those common interests outside of values
and direction
uh don't matter as much yeah and just
because something's not coming up right
now
doesn't mean it never will so that if
you're if you have a
if you are in a relationship if you're
dating somebody you can't
maintain sort of political neutrality or
moral neutrality religious neutrality
especially in a long term
right you could only do that if you
don't if you don't really want to be
with them right
right if you don't really want to share
the kinds of things you have to share in
a marriage
is the only way you can get any further
down the road and inevitably it will
cause a problem yes
no exactly and i would even go so far as
to say the common interest in a marriage
in many ways aren't necessary you know i
have some i'm i
my wife and i we actually if we go to
the movie theater we both want to see
the same movie we both read the same
book so we are an example of we have a
lot of common interests but i have
friends who probably have almost
zero common interest but their marriage
still works great because they share
those values and i think it actually
you know opposites can attract it can be
interesting and exciting to have someone
who
has interests that are well my brother
and his wife for example they
share a lot in common they have the same
sense of humor they both worked in media
um they are interested in a lot of the
same things they're both very
you know they like to be around each
other all the time my wife and i are
actually pretty
i would say independent in the sense
that my wife can be downstairs reading a
book
or she can be reading a book while i'm
watching a documentary and we're
perfectly happy you know we have the
dogs with us
um and and we're in each other's company
right it's about quality time
but it also does come down to in
relationships esteeming your partner
first and so when i look for a movie
that we're going to watch together if my
wife will say hey i'm tired maybe
like to watch a movie tonight could you
pick one i think we've all had this
conversation the biggest fights i ever
got to in my life was with a girlfriend
back not in a video store because you
know the physicality of it just makes
you want to like find the hard edge and
um not that you did you didn't do that
right yeah i thought you said you
weren't muslim no
no i always found a nearby child that's
why you got to bring the magnetron with
you
as soon as she reaches for it you go oh
i'm sorry
i already touched um but so if she says
hey
try and find a movie i will try and find
something my wife enjoys and i find
something that i like that my wife likes
for example she loves like those early
90s thrillers like you know primal fear
like basic attract fatal attraction
basic instinct those kinds of things uh
i think the
film like frailty these kinds and i
enjoy those too
now there are certain comedies that i'll
enjoy that i know i mean my wife just
isn't going to like
but she'll also look and find some
comedies that she thinks okay we can
watch together now there are certain
lines that are drawn for example married
at first sight
don't do it i did bachelor when we were
i did bachelor for the first two years
of her marriage and i said sweet
i can't do it anymore if it's a show
with a [ __ ] on tlc being pushed off a
boat
i don't want to watch it like i can't do
that but i will
go with you on these other journeys
see i'll i'll preface it with i'll go
into your movie but you got to know i'm
going to make fun of it
like i'm going to make fun of it that
was me with a bachelor for a long time
and then she thought that it became it
grew tiresome
which she didn't know it grew tired that
was by design wait the show or you
go yeah me but that was by design i'm
like i'm just going to make this such a
miserable experience
there we go i can never be accused of
not supporting her
but i'm not going to have to watch
desiree pick from 16. so you want to be
able to do you don't want to watch the
bachelor she doesn't want you to watch
the video exactly
you'd watch the bachelor so i go read a
book on churchill
and we both go our separate ways on the
flip side with men
and i want to know people out there i
guess this is kind of question for you
what do you find
how do you see the connections uh being
different between
sort of your friendships namely your
same-sex friendships that's probably a
whole other discussion i don't
really know that men and women can be
really good friends
uh i think you can like for example i
work with courtney and we have a
professional agent we're from afar but i
don't think my wife would ever be okay
with me hanging out with
a woman as often as i hang out with
people here gerald alone
sure um you know mike pence was dragged
through the mud right but i won't go out
to dinner
because he all he basically said was hey
if i'm going to cheesecake factory with
a dame i'm going to make sure that
there's somebody else present so i don't
get me too
oh my gosh she hates women this was pre
me too so they didn't even have a label
basic like just don't hang out with
girls alone
and really cheesecake factory should
have been the most upset because he said
that their meals were always
uh he said it was aggressively mediocre
yeah always disappointing
always always whereas olive garden
you're not disappointed because you know
exactly what you get there you go it's
about expectation
yeah it's exactly about expectations um
so let us know what you think about that
as far as what those commonalities are i
will say with jujitsu there was a guy
who
really a great guy we ended up becoming
good friends um and
he was advanced at this point he was
purple but was really close to being a
brown belt
and i had some instructors for a long
time who wanted me to compete and so
they would hold me back at white and it
blew
and so that's so you can win more medals
which it really isn't fair they call it
sandbagging and i always wanted to get
to advance because i didn't really feel
good being better than people in my
category
but i rolled this guy who was kind of
top dog at school and when we were
rolling
um he got really mad because he was
having a tough time and so he turned it
up on me and i could feel him like he
got aggressive and then so then i turned
it up
and then and then it turned into a
full-fledged fight it's like we were
fighting before with less intensity yeah
but now there were elbows grinding and
like he
and then all he got we both got up he's
like yeah you want to go i'm like you
sure again you want to go outside so
we'll change we just we won't have mats
and then uh after that we got into a
fight turned out that he was going
through a rough period in his
relationship and he did he called me and
he said hey man
i'm sorry it's just you know like
obviously this is something that means
it's a big part of my identity right now
i'm going through this rough time in my
personal life he said i shouldn't have
done that
i'm the more advanced student i should
be he said i'm really starting you know
what i'm really sorry because i should
have sort of
i should have given you the right of way
and after that
we were each other's best training
partners we were joking we were having
fun it never got super competitive
we were relatively evenly matched you
know where the lines are you know where
the lines are but it took the in our
common interest we did share values we
happened to
but i've had other people in jitsu we're
always sharing common issues is jiu
jitsu
i would see them four or five times a
week at this point in my life and never
see them outside of it but we were
pretty close
yeah and we knew when we went to
tournaments that we had each other's
backs that we would be there cornering
each other that we would be kind of
helping each other warm up
that's important men are task focused
task oriented you need to have an
activity that you accomplish together
and that forges a bond and men are
respect oriented as well so being able
to respect the other person that
that is what forges friendships respect
and loyalty is the two main things
yeah absolutely yeah and that's the case
that
can be the case in a marriage as well i
mean if if a wife doesn't respect her
husband that
you know that will it's not a good base
stop the identity from the man and we'll
also
just destroy that yeah women tend to
receive
love more so in tenderness and kindness
in being gentle and being compassionate
in listening and men sort of receive
love very often
in forms of respect and service and
appreciation that doesn't mean good in
the kitchen you're making me a sandwich
but you know what
it'll melt your husband's heart if he
comes home and you make a really good
meal because you just did it because you
love him and you know that he loves that
chicken piccata it's better than
cheesecake factory you know the point
again chicken piccata chicken piccata
for anyone listening what do you mean
what did i say no that you want the
chicken piccata
oh yes can i just tell you
my mind goes crazy things when we're
talking about stuff and i thought to
myself when we were earlier
i know is i thought if there was a
restaurant that audio wade would love
the most it's the freaking encyclopedia
tome that is the candle the the
cheesecake factory menu
because he loves to read so much and i
can see him being like a lot of options
none of them are great none of it's bad
but none of it's very good yes
correct overpriced and just mediocre i
mean if you're if you're if your steak
is getting shown up by dave and busters
[Laughter]
right next to the whack-a-mole you gotta
up your game but they do got a good
location cheesecake factory that's what
they do they find a good corner
you know they're in a shopping mall
although i don't really know how
valuable that is
but yeah no i think probably the same
thing you probably have members in your
band their half asian
uh bill where you probably don't have a
lot of commonality outside of music with
some of them
but when you're there it doesn't matter
you're close because you're doing
something together well we're close and
they are all very respectful like we i
think i've told you guys this before we
we did some touring before a couple
years ago and you're in a van and a lot
of time and we're talking and like i'm
still working on lawyering
lawyerly stuff in the morning or
whatever but every day we would pick a
different topic driving between cities
and talk and i would say i'll take
either side
whatever side you want me to take if
you're you know whatever you think you
are and i'll argue the other side
whatever it is so typically it was me
arguing the conservative side
yeah um and and every time it was you're
sort of a backseat lawyer
uh yes constantly that sounds like fun
yeah sure it was great it's not arguing
about turn signals but he's arguing
about mensarea
[Laughter]
and uh and so then you know we but it
was respect it was a respect and a
learning and an openness right here and
consider
and and that was a thing that that
allowed us to have that kanban and then
we would bond over
you know white castle at two in the
morning in louisville because that's
what was open yeah and in music
as you're playing with playing in a band
sort of context you can
be impressed with each other so like
watch somebody do something they're very
skilled at and just be able to
be wowed by somebody even if you have
again different political views
different religions that also comes down
to temperament because some people
see someone else here who is successful
i think that's a big difference between
leftists and conservatives uh in a lot
of ways
when i see someone who's a billionaire
when i see someone who's very wealthy i
don't
get mad at them i don't think they must
have screwed someone and i go oh my god
what is this guy doing i go that guy man
to be his or when i see someone who's
really good at jiu jitsu when i used to
watch him like
what is he doing and i'll ask him how
are you training and inevitably they're
doing something that i'm not they're
doing something better than i'm doing
but there are some people
who will get mad and get jealous or try
to pull you down if they know that
you're better than them and that's
someone you can't be friends with and
i've had relationships like that where
they're friends with you and this
happens in the comedy community you're
doing stand-up comedy
then all of a sudden i got into the just
for laughs and people who were saying
that i was good
uh were gone huh i was like he took my
spot
no i just did listen you're great and i
would say you're probably better than me
but i just had a better showing that
night you know it was my night
so that is i think something that comes
down to respect and apprecia mutual
respect
and i think the left tends to think in
terms of zero some games and and
whereas people on the right don't so if
again there are lots of spots there are
lots of
opportunities for you to advance maybe
next year and again
but everybody thinks that if that one
spot and just for laughs is taken
again that there's no spot for you to
advance yeah that's my spot
i was gonna be the number one star in
the world
i did a word i got to work with the
wonderful and margaret
a knockout the number one star in the
world it was his old book
but uh i will say this too when you talk
about mutual respect if you find someone
who's excellent at something
someone who's kind of good at something
but not really and
you want to sort of sit at their feet
and learn they often try to make it seem
like it's something you can't do
someone who is a master someone who is
genuinely good and accomplished and
knows that they are
one of the best um they're usually
actually pretty happy to try and impart
that wisdom with someone else that's
been my experience
i've gone up to world ch so i just say
jiu jitsu because it's something i've
done for a long time
um comedy is a very hyper competitive
even though
people trying to act like it's community
it's not but ninjutsu have gone up to
world champions go man how did you get
this guillotine to work and they go like
oh
let me show you but i've had people who
are kind of so so how you do that like
man it's just doing it for a long time
you have to do for a lot and they want
to make it seem like there's some
barrier to entry
and that's because people who are really
good the language they speak
is respect if you show appreciation and
respect to someone
rather than jealousy and this applies to
people who run successful businesses
people who have successful marriages
in most cases there are exceptions to
the rule people who are excellent
they want to see other people be
excellent because they're kind of in a
league of their own
and let me end it with this before we
tell youtube to take a hike uh for
people who are mug club members of
course this continues behind the pay
wall live credit com slash mug club
um my grandfather was a full colonel in
the air force he would have been general
but he didn't have a high school i
didn't have a college degree i mean he
had a high school degree
and he was a guy who trained all of the
fighter pilots basically all the elite
kind of fighter pilots in the air force
and so he was flying every day he was an
officer he was out there flying
every day and his kids didn't really
realize my parents would say they'd be
like uh
dad ah dad dinner dinner i don't want
sloppy joes whatever they were
complaining
about you know back then because they
had sloppy joes and if they asked for
steak he's like who are we the rocket
feelers
everyone has steak uh but he would
they would say that and he'd go you
little sh
i was do you know where i was today i
was over portland
and then canada sacramento and back
before your final
school bell rang do you have any idea
what i'd do each day
it's just like he had the coolest job
and no one appreciated it
because it was their dad and so if
you're a wife if you're
a son that is something i think goes a
long way with men and women
let me know what's equal what goes a
long way with you because we always want
to learn and you're a rubik's creed that
we just can't figure out our last
not takashi we're not rubik's cube
experts but right now
youtube piss off we're going to my club